- I have one bone to pick with you.
- Okay.
- So like with "Saved By The Bell" reboot,
I know that somebody had
to sing the theme song.
- Yes.
- Yeah, who was that?
- You know what?
We actually had Lil Yachty. (laughs)
- Okay, fine, that's fine.
- Can I tell you something, Kelly, though?
- [Kelly] I would have totally done it.
- First though, okay.
- I just sang the whole thing
before you came out here with Jesse.
- I was hearing you backstage.
- Okay.
- You know I love you,
you know you're my favorite.
- [Kelly] I'm just saying,
it would have me amazing.
- I know you would have killed it.
- Lil Yachty was probably amazing.
- I always tell everyone
because you know...
First of all, thank you so much
for filling in for me on my radio show,
when we did the countdown.
Everyone over at On With Mario loves you.
You know we're big, big
fans, but I always say,
I feel sorry for the other artists
when you do the KellyOkies,
'cause you do their songs so much.
(Kelly laughs)
I'm not lying, you usually
take it next level,
and it's so much better, I go,
oh my God, I would buy that one.
- Sometimes it doesn't work.
My favorite thing that
anyone's ever said to me,
Garth Brooks was on the show and he goes,
"Is there any genre you wouldn't go near?"
And I was like, there are genres
I shouldn't go near, but I do it.
- No, no, you're killing 'em all.
- I love music.
- I know.
- [Kelly] So that's what's
cool about your job too,
you get to like celebrate all music.
- Yes, I love music too.
I love music, I love entertainment.
That's why I love doing
Access Hollywood and all that.
- How has it been?
'Cause COVID's weird.
So how's it been doing the radio show,
Access Hollywood, all of it?
- You know what?
We really haven't stopped, to be honest.
We did it a little bit at home.
I was shooting out in my backyard
with Access Hollywood and-
- I had to do it out of my
backyard for a while too.
- Yeah, for a little while.
But then we were the
first show, I believe,
on the lot back with access,
which is great, which is nice
because we're celebrating
our 25 year anniversary.
And we're really excited
over there about that.
And then On With Mario, with the show,
we do it on the lot as well.
So everything's sorta
consolidated right here.
So we kinda kept on going.
Between that, and then I
did my Christmas movie,
"Feliz NaviDAD" over in Nevada.
So I've been keeping really busy.
- [Kelly] Nevada's beautiful.
- And the new "Saved By The Bell" so yeah.
- That's amazing, I love Christmas.
I will watch any Christmas movie.
I love Christmas so much.